kim kardashian kendall jenner drake and
moore speak out following eight deaths
and hundreds of injuries at travis
scott's astro world festival over the
weekend
on monday both kim and kendall shared
messages of support for travis and the
victims on their insta stories kim
writing quote absolutely heartbroken for
the lives who were lost and anyone who
was hurt at astroworld just like all of
you our family is in shock by the
tragedy we are keeping all of the
victims families and loved ones impacted
in our prayers for healing as well as
travis who we know cares so much about
his fans and is truly devastated kim's
sister khloe kardashian and their mom
kris jenner reposted her story on their
pages meanwhile their younger sister
kendall wrote her own post saying in
part quote sending everyone who has been
affected all my love and wishing them
strength during this incredibly
devastating and sensitive time kendall
attended the astroworld festival with
her sister travis's partner kylie jenner
sharing videos from the crowd on
instagram prior to having knowledge
about the deaths that occurred
[Music]
kylie who is currently expecting her
second child with travis also posted
videos from the event which she attended
with their three-year-old daughter
stormy webster the kylie cosmetics
founder previously shared her
condolences on instagram writing in part
that she and travis are quote broken and
devastated and adding my thoughts and
prayers are with all who lost their
lives were injured or affected in any
way by yesterday's events and also for
travis who i know cares deeply for his
fans and the houston community
now drake who performed on friday night
alongside the rapper is speaking out too
in his statement he reveals that his
quote heart is broken for the victims
and their families i will continue to
pray for all of them and will be of
service in any way i can may god be with
you all houston is my hometown it's a
special place in my heart
i feel terrible houston native megan the
stallion shared what was on her heart
during a chat with e.t on monday night
whatever we could do i want to help i
want to support all ways that's my duty
that's what i got to do and we're just
sending prayers and we send in
condolences and we send in positive
energy to everybody in that family
earlier that day tmz reported that
travis and live nation are facing
multiple lawsuits which claim they
failed to provide adequate security and
a security plan to protect attendees
according to variety the 30 year old
rapper will provide full refunds for all
astro world attendees i just want to
send out prayers to the
to the ones that was lost the outlet
also reported that travis will not
perform at this weekend's day in vegas
festival where he was scheduled to
headline
i could just never imagine the severity
of the situation replacing travis post
malone who was announced via the
festival's twitter page
we're actually working right now
to identify the families
so we can help assist them through this
tough time
and now according to multiple reports
travis is funding the funeral costs for
the eight victims and e.t has learned
that he is partnering with better help
to offer mental health services for free
to anyone who attended the festival who
may need to talk through their trauma my
fans really mean the world to me